From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Monday, March 11, 2013. My name is John Dittmer and I'm here in Durant, Mississippi with videographer John Bishop to interview Mr. Walter Bruce, a leading civil rights activist in the Holmes County Movement.
This interview will become part of the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture in Washington, D.C.
First of all, Mr. Bruce, we're delighted to be here today and thank you for taking the time to talk with us.
I'd like to begin by asking you about your home and family. Were you born and raised in Holmes County?
Yes, I was in a little community called Rolling Wall out in the country. That's what I was born in. What did your parents do?
They got a little share of crop and just a little bit and I know what I'm doing.
What was it like to be growing, were you on a plantation then?
Not just a plantation, we don't know. Whitefoot had some land out there but we wouldn't like to deal with anything.
If you want to have crops, you can do it. What was your start picking cotton?
I never picked my little cotton. I hope it's good but I can't remember no cotton.
I bet you don't regret not being able to. When did you move to Durant at what point?
He was in the early 60s. You were back there in Rosewater?
Rosewater. Tell us something about your childhood experiences. What you remember growing up in that area of the county?
Growing up out there, being a teenager. A whole lot of people lived out in that community.
I formed a little league, baseball team. I ran it for about 15 or 16 years. Then I started a gospel group and on into the civil right movement.
I talked about the gospel group a little later. Where did you go to school?
I started off at the Roe Wall. When I finished out there, I went to Ambrole School in Latin.
Tell us something about your teachers and subjects.
I was there. You got an 8th grade and then I moved in Latin. I had a sister in Latin.
I finished 12th grade at Ambrole High School. Now they got to New School with my claim. At that time, Ambrole High School.
It was rather unusual for people to finish high school, wasn't it?
So you liked studying?
Yeah, I liked it.
What do you remember about your teachers?
Well, not in a whole lot. It's been a long time. I was teaching at the end of the day.
We were quite different from then and now.
Did you have brothers and sisters?
Yeah, I had 13 of them, six brothers and seven sisters. All of them had a way with me.
Oh, wow. Where were you on the list?
On the baby.
You were the baby of the family.
You probably had brothers and sisters as adults when you were growing up.
Oh, yes, you.
And they had kids you played with. And you were their uncle.
Yeah, man.
Could we call this for a distance?
The problem?
Okay, we're back.
Okay.
Just take up work.
Yeah, just take up work.
Okay. We were talking about school.
What about church?
Was church important in your family?
Yeah, all my family was changed.
So Baptist?
Methodist.
Methodist. I see.
Tell us something about what you remember from church and the importance for your family.
Well, when I was at that road wall, we had a little wooden church.
A couple of miles from where we stayed, but we used to walk over it.
We had like two sons of a month.
But we had to, I know, remember the creek right in between Iowa, Hoppe and the church.
We always cut a tree and threw it.
Throw it down with some blanked up bay and roll.
That's what we went to church.
We had an animal call, anything like that.
Wow.
So your folks were supporting 13 kids.
Were they able to do that on cotton, on chair capping?
Yeah.
That must have been everybody pitching in.
How many acres did your father...
We didn't own an acre.
How large was the area you farmed?
We didn't.
It wasn't all always for him.
Maybe like two or three acres of the farm.
Oh really?
Oh, I see.
So it was...
Yeah.
And did you fly behind the mule?
Yes, I applied a little bit.
I mean, one time when I was small, I wanted to fly this one.
And never done that.
Never did I pull it.
You know, the moon was started.
I had been asking my dad, he didn't let me fly.
So the day that he said, I have to meet a fly.
And then he told me that day that I won't be able to fly.
I called it a star.
He got out and there was a white put a deer on it.
Bird was in there.
Oh man.
Yes.
And he had...
And his star got out and when they went up by, he's out.
And put him in the foward, you know.
And when they were about to give him, he told me, you know, he had to pay $1 a year to get him.
And he told me, now, $1 a year.
And so finally, he came back to the house and told me that he couldn't give him, because he didn't have no money.
And so I finally got to drop on him.
And so, as he kind of disappeared, then I went up there by myself and knocked on the door.
And what he went with me, I said, I can't hear my little me.
Did he tell you that you were going to have a dollar of peace?
I said, yeah, he told me that I didn't have no love.
And I said, well, I tell you what, I tell you you don't let him out, I'm gonna let him out of my self.
And he said, it's all gone.
And then the boy had a little me.
And boy, he got no sense.
That's interesting.
So you stood up to him?
Yeah.
Tell us something about race relations.
How many whites were there in the area?
What were your other contacts?
Well, white in the air was heavy, probably, you know, when the moon was starting.
He was more white in the city.
But the county, you know, most men told him black, but, you know, at that time, you couldn't tell him,
the white air control was heavy.
Yeah.
One of the things we were talking about children today, not realizing about the old times.
And of course, one of the major factors of life back then was Jim Crow segregation.
For these younger people, tell us what it was like to live in a segregated society.
Well, it was kind of rough, you know, but like I said, I guess, you know,
at that time, you know, it wasn't too hard to get along with, but, you know,
it wasn't too much you could do about it.
But, you know, we kind of got along.
As I said now, at all the time that I've been in the moon or even for them,
I never hated white for right.
It didn't like what they were waiting, you know, did it.
But I needed hating them, you know, like that, like that.
But whoever I had to say or do, I just, you know, going to do it.
Was there any, are any racial incidents, any violence or anything that you remember
around when you were growing up?
Well, that's about the only thing that I knew about, you know, is that I said,
when the stock got out of there, well, we, we, you know, not too far apart, you know,
we kind of communicated together, but I never had no more problem after that happened.
How old were you when you went up there?
Oh, about 27 or 8.
Oh, no, getting.
What a wonderful story.
Yeah.
It was awesome that the second is coming in the role.
What kind of law enforcement do you remember in police sheriff?
Were they visible presence?
Not too much.
I mean, all at that time, you know, all safe from police problems, all white.
But basically, is it safe to say that, that you had limited contact with white stirring
you're growing up years?
I didn't know I know a lot of problems I'd grown up.
Most problems I had with them was in the early 60s.
Yeah, well, we're going to get to that soon.
Did you rephrase the question?
Well, I think that you were growing up and you had limited contacts with whites.
Was it black community and you saved pretty much in the black community?
Did you work at all outside the home other than sharecropping?
Oh, yeah.
Well, I said, I was a common problem for my up, for my 16-year birth,
they own owned up to every time.
Well, I want you to talk about that.
Did you have the skills to be a carpenter?
Did you apprentice yourself to someone or did you just pick it up?
No, I told some of them, I mean, that question, I told them,
I never went to school to be a carp.
And so, it was just a great gift from God.
Then I started out calming and I don't know how I'm in a house.
I was getting a house kind of a taller county, old 60, I spent.
Did you have a crew working with you?
I had two more friends working with me.
And who bought these?
Who were you building these homes for?
I built some of white and brown.
After I got you started in the civil right and moved,
I mean, when I first started, I was thinking that I wasn't on white going high,
and that's what I was thinking about when I got started in the civil right movement.
But then I think the whole run of them,
they were kind of friends, they didn't have them, maybe I would have.
Do something against that bend.
So you were a contractor when you were a teenager,
or did you just start hiring out to yourself?
When did you build your first house?
Do you remember that at all?
No, I know I can't really...
The first one I was...
I'm trying to think what you want to know.
But are your houses still, are some of them still standing?
All of them.
All of them are still standing.
Yeah, everyone.
Wow.
So you can just drive around the county and you can see what you did.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Yeah, and you were a singer.
How did you get to be a singer?
Well, just like you said, you're like,
I'm an art and baseball team.
All my life, that's almost I ever did a fool around with people.
You know, from teenage, you don't want to add up.
And then we started this group.
And this page, October, we celebrated our 54-year-old good.
Wow.
So tell us about what kind of songs...
Who else was in the group, what kind of songs did you sing?
Where did you sing?
We sung, we sang all night, two homes, kind of,
Tallahowne, Lee Floreau, Counting, Waterloo Chicago.
Wow.
Me and Walker.
So you were well known outside this thing?
Oh, sure.
And you did a lot of touring, did you?
Yeah, we did a whole lot.
You did.
When were you most popular?
When was your group the most popular?
Well, we still put it popular.
But you did radio broadcasts?
We do radio broadcasts right now.
It was fun.
Wow.
What's the station?
W-H-T-N-L-E.
Wow.
You make any records?
Yeah.
Well, we make...
Getting ready to make a number, we got...
Going solo, just about...
I got some...
Maybe I have one, I know I got some tape, plenty of tapes in here.
But those CD, they go real fast.
Yeah.
Are all the members of your original group still in it?
Or have you had replacements?
Well, we don't have the whole lot of them.
The whole lot of them passed away.
Yeah.
Most of them...
I'm the only one that's been in there for 50-something years.
I've already read them since then.
Because one of them then started out with me, all of them, and passed away.
Well, music was very important in the Civil Rights Movement.
Yes, it was.
Talk a little bit about that.
Why it was that there was so much music and what it did for people.
Well, I think...
I say what the Black was going through, and they just got connected, you know, with the church and gospel songs,
and all like that.
And I sound like they like the blues, but most of the people that went to church all the time,
they really liked that gospel singing.
And then did you were the...
Was singing a major part of the mass meetings that you had?
Yeah, we always were proud of the song.
We had all the kind of why I mean we call them.
Well, let's then turn to the Civil Rights Movement in Holmes County, and in Mississippi, and your role ended.
What are your first recollections of the Civil Rights Movement underway?
Well, if I were, you know, growing up and seeing everything, you know, they were going on.
And I was just going to...
Yes, that right after the first beginning, I wasn't as active as I was a little late on because,
as I said, by me being a contractor, you know, and I was wanting to know if I was taking the part in the Civil Rights Movement,
you know, would I be able to get the jobs and find that I was getting?
I don't know, then something just kind of means that, well, what good is a job?
You ain't got no freedom.
And so when I just went on and did what I had to do, and then things didn't go away, I just let them know who I felt about it.
And so that's where I really got started.
So, I...
Do you remember, well, there were a number of things that have been sort of influential in the Civil Rights Movement?
Unfortunately, some of them acts of violence. You remember when Emmett Till was killed?
Yeah.
Tell us about your...
You were what in your 20s then?
Yeah.
What was the conversation around here? What were you feeling?
Well, I mean, everybody around him was, you know, just really upset, you know,
but we knew that, you know, certain things like that might have come.
And at that time, you know, I didn't know just to give a sense of blessing to God that I never got hurt, you know, from what I was involved in.
And all these different places that I was going to, and all these different times of night coming in.
And it just roughed back there, but people all around me, when I was praying, I took no time, that I would be afraid of.
And when I, when I'd give it a come into the house, I said, well, I was, you know, right or no, I never thought too much about it.
But you were trying to have that feeling when you get out to be here, you know, and give it a come in the house or something like that.
You had that feeling.
You might have felt that when you were seven, eight years old and confronting that white man that he could have retaliated to in the same way.
Where?
Yeah.
Did you have kids in, when, when, Emmett Till was lynched and if so, we got to know he went moan.
Yeah, so you didn't have to deal with your kids and talk to them about it.
Yeah, a number of movement people, the younger, slick people say that's when they decided because Till was a boy their own age.
Yeah, right.
And that they were going to come here and do something about it.
Yeah.
What exactly, what, what, what's the Emmett Till story? What happened?
He, what they did was saying he was the thumb out of white later over there.
That's what they, they were, they were stored out.
But I don't think that happened.
I think it is.
He probably involved in the civil right movement I think and that's when they decided they had him.
It was, it was a, it was a big story.
It wasn't all over the nation.
Yeah, it was.
It was, it wasn't that far from here either.
No, green was about, about 50 to 60 miles from here.
What did you first hear about Medgar Evers in the NAACP?
Well, after I, I mean I heard something about them, you know, he never thought I was the civil right movement.
After civil right movement got started and then I, you know, heard a whole lot about him then and they're like,
when you go to read me and Jackson and Tugelone, all of them different phrases and I knew a whole lot about him.
Did you, did you meet him and talk with him in those days?
Yeah, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, you know.
You come up here to speak?
Yeah, yeah.
And Aaron Henry?
Yeah.
You know him, real weird.
Yeah, even then, he re-elected in the movement.
Well, I want to talk a little bit about the factors that led you to believe, to get involved in the civil rights movement.
What was it?
Was there any one thing or was it just you saw people doing things?
You were running a risk because you could lose business.
What made you overcome that and become active?
Well, as I said, I really got started in the mood, you know, going to these different places and I would, you know, see how the white folk would, you know, go on the black folk, you're like, we, because he was most started out in the mice and communities and the Delta.
And most of every time we would go down there to meet and then we would get back up to the highway, which was highway 12.
It, they are somebody going, oh, we get stopped there, you know, this, you know, the ticket, you know, you violated or not, they just, give you a ticket, I just trying to stop, you know, from going down there to the, to the mean.
But every time we did, we had a mean on that, somebody going to, two or three people, you're going to get a ticket.
Did you, because start going to these meetings and 62, 63, or was it later?
No, in the 60.
Yeah, yeah, did you, did you attend any of the meetings in Greenwood?
Yeah, I wouldn't meet any of the greenwood, too.
Okay, what, what, what talks about the SNCC people who were around here?
Well, SNCC people, you know, they, they, they, they were around here for years.
I mean, they were, they were real active and, you know, they, and most of every time we had a meeting, you know, we'll be some of them would be there.
And they were very active, you know, and directly, you know, and kind of helped you get everything lined up, they were real active.
One of the major stories of the Mississippi Civil Rights Movement was, was the Freedom Summer of 1964.
When you had upwards of a thousand volunteers, most of them young white people, coming into the state to do voter registration, to work in community centers, to organize, help organize the organization.
Yeah.
There were more than 30 volunteers in Holmes County.
Tell us what you remember about that stuff.
Right. I remember, you know, when they were coming in here and there, like when we, you know, was trying to get registered to, what we'd be able to vote.
And, and so they would be here to help us out.
So when we first started to vote in here, we had to do our, I mean, register.
We were done in the basement of the post office there in the election called them, let you do it in the cold article.
Whenever you go to the cold article, they register, they would know the right people, you know, couldn't read too well.
And they, again, was Jackson, they had a new pick.
And they couldn't read that, new paper they wouldn't have registered.
And they also asked you, how many strands of hair did you have in your hair?
And you couldn't have that question when they were not voting.
And they also asked you, quote, like, if you sort of a five gallon bucket of water, how many, and drop a bar, so many, how many bubbles would it be?
Yeah. That was very difficult.
Very, very difficult.
About the summer itself, where, where they're, I mean, with a lot of these young white folks coming around, what impact did that have on the community?
The number of them lived with local people living things?
Yeah, it's outside people.
Yeah, they stayed with the black folks when they coming here, most of them, you know, not white people didn't like that, but they didn't, they didn't snitch them on them.
They wasn't afraid of them.
So, whatever we wanted to do, they read that water.
So, you were active in the summer project then?
Yeah.
What do you remember about specific other than the voting part, which we're going to get to shortly, of how that summer went down?
Well, I said it finally, no, as we know, just kept on meaning and going on in there.
I guess on that page of that, you know, then we had to go back and they had to move all our name up to the cold island from the post office, you know, we had to re-rest it, to get change the vote.
But all that was, they just didn't really want to re-rest the vote.
And after the Freedom Summer, I'm going to get into voting shortly.
But after Freedom Summer, why you also had the Meredith March against fear?
What do you remember about? Did you march it all in that?
What was the atmosphere like that?
Well, anything, you know, that come up, that we didn't like, well, you know, then we might have a meal and the side what we're going to do, or either just like that time.
It hit about a 16 or 17 community with the Freedom Democratic Party.
But right now, home's kind of the ones who want to steal, got the party going.
And so we meet up and decide what we're going to do.
And the SNS people, they were always being there with us.
We always make the decision, you know, and then they were going on with us.
And sometimes they're having an idea what we need to do.
And we went right close together.
Yeah, very few blocks were registered to vote.
And then in April of 1963, 14 homes county blocks went to the courthouse to attempt to register.
Yeah. The first 14. Tell us what you remember about those people in that time.
Well, I knew all of the people that went up there, and that's when they laughed on them,
and they were different questions about this.
The bucket was soaked in the high stride and had all those people there,
the first 14 and went up there with some masks.
And I knew all of them.
Tell us about one of those people, Hartman Turnbull.
On Turnbull's toe.
Yeah, he was nice and old because he had a loud, heavy voice in the wind.
And so he would speak out.
You have any Turnbull stories? Everybody had the Hesse in the Hesse.
Oh, yeah, we tell us of him.
He'd always come and study when he told me.
He had a powerful speech, though, that he made, yeah.
He was real active.
And I said, I knew all of them that the boys were 14 and went up there.
Ralph Hase?
Ralph Hase.
He tells us about Mr. Hase.
What did he do for a living and what was his role?
I think most of them went about really kind of share crop,
but most of them went up there.
They owned their own, despite not in the mass and community.
They had Russian, Whitaker, James Boyne, all of them.
Yeah, I read where because they owned their own farms,
they had more independence.
They picked off the plantation.
Yeah, they couldn't be kicked out, but you know,
somebody would go down there, you know,
and get them out of nine, or they'd know, you know,
the wife would know, they'd go out there and try to get the rest
and all that.
They're going to try to protest against all that, didn't they?
And so then I guess they just met up with their mind,
and they were gone, whatever they were going to get ready
to be able to vote.
Yeah, things really started to get violent
when it's black started to assert their rights.
Turnbo's house was fired into bird.
Bob Moses came up, you remember Bob?
Yeah, Bob Moses.
How about Alma Mitchell Carnegie?
Yes, you good.
Yeah, her, as a queen, all of them, nine out,
and some of them were in屋,
but they were nine in the edge of their house.
And as a queen, she got on the outside of the hill.
She went from she was school up there.
But those, as I said, I'm old, I'm 14,
I'm old, all of them live in屋.
Yeah, they came up to try to get rest of the boat.
A number of people from Holmes County went to Jackson
for the demonstrations in the summer of 65
and got thrown in jail at the fairgrounds.
And did you know any of those people?
Yeah, I knew some of them.
Were you one of them?
I didn't, I don't think I went to them.
You were getting put in jail and I got put in jail in a long time.
When were you put in jail?
Oh, in the early, early 60s, early 60s, I was there.
What did they get you for?
Well, what happened to Jay Young,
he lived between him, West,
and some out, he went to the Lakson.
They locked him up.
Me like he was drunk or something like that.
But then we knew that wasn't true.
I've been on and played ball with him.
I never knew him to drink.
So they locked him up.
When he did have a bad heart.
And I think that they refused to give him that medicine.
And so that morning when they went in there, they found him dead.
Then, named as Haltow,
we went over there to see what happened.
And when we woke up, cared more,
to say it, then I asked him,
because we said, no, y'all can't sense it.
He's not eating bread.
I told my daughter, I don't want bread.
I said, I want to see him like he is.
He said, well, you can't see him.
And I said, you know what?
I said, it's going to be better on you if you let us see him.
And so, well, I'm going to tell you, go on, have your girl.
I'm too going to be able to go on it.
And I wanted to look at him all the time.
I couldn't find no scar.
And the thing, you know what?
He had been beaten up here and anything like that.
And I said, I looked at him all the way over.
And then we come out of them.
We decided to put on that boycott.
And then, and that, everyone on for a few days,
maybe a week or more.
And so we had a community of stone.
And so I was in the stone of it every time.
Was it a giraffe now or?
That was an election.
Luxembourg.
And so, I was on the stone,
the clock, all of us wet together.
And anything that happened, home was kind of going all the way,
you know, confronting me.
And she coming told me that they want you to come to the
lecture, that they're unlocked up to 12 people.
And so when I got ready to go to the lecture,
and I got ready to walk out the stone in the shed,
and then the devil was coming in the stone.
And they said, well, we got him one for you, a red.
And I said, okay.
So they came in on, got in the car,
and we were going to the lecture, what the hell?
You got me for it.
And he said, they said, you hold the people's old,
that is the march.
And I said, well, you must don't know who bowed that damn drum.
I said, that truck knows me.
I said, I hold anything, I'm body and I want to.
And so they came on and locked us up.
And so then one too long for my wife and brother came over
to get me out, but I tried to know, I'm not going to get out of
it now, because we all are going to stay in there together.
We all are going to get out together.
These were the other 12 they had.
And so, and then, I think his name was,
who he was hooker, but he'd born all us out.
And so they kept counting around the Jackson in different
places, you know, kind of.
You know, it's convict, but we, we were there in the same night
that we got in there.
There were so many people in the lesson that you couldn't even walk
around the street.
And so when we got out of jail, then we formed another mall.
And then we went to the malls and around the square,
and they were running upside of me, the white wall.
So you can get them to stop the malls and all that.
And we just kept going, and they said, well, we,
if they don't stop the mall, we're going to lock them up.
So they parked the car and told them, they're all getting
and so, and so everybody, they just filled the car,
the main thing that was driving, the police that was driving,
the car couldn't even get in there.
There were so many people in there, and then they made them all
get out.
And so it was kind of fun and dangerous too, but you know,
we, whatever we planned to do, we decided to do,
we going and do it.
And so then they found them, and then we finally called it all
after, you know, we kind of got what we were expecting
and asked for, and so then we called it all for that mall.
So with a, you got out of jail and you went right back on the street?
Right back on the street.
The word intimidated at all, but.
No, no.
Thinking you'd probably get arrested again.
I didn't, we didn't care then.
Yeah, well, you arrested any other times?
No, that's on time that I was arrested.
How were you treated in jail?
Well, nobody ever come around.
Most of all of them, you know, all of them in the same city
I was close to jail.
But we were nobody, we were about getting in or getting out.
And you were in there for how long?
May were two or three hours.
It was real, I don't know exactly.
Yeah.
It was scary.
You know, it had scary.
I've been arrested in a couple of times.
Oh yeah.
Oh, you don't know what's going to happen to you.
But I said, you know the folk was together back in the 60s, 64 on the own up and up.
And I said, no, so I never seen that many people on that square on all my life.
It was that night.
I mean, you couldn't even walk around that square.
The streets were full.
And the road all around that square.
I like to talk a little bit about the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party.
But were you involved at the beginning in the early 1964 when the party was formed?
Tell us about what you were doing in Holmes County because you were getting ready to challenge the all white segregationist Democratic delegation
at the National Convention in Atlantic City.
How did you go about that?
Well, when the first started out, the Freedom Democratic Party, they were when they elected President, you know, for the first president that they elected, you know, he would have like two years.
And I think it was three here on me.
And so when they, time was up, then they elected me.
That's what I teed about some other time.
I said, now when I was elected to be in the chair of the Freedom Democratic Party, I said, it was just only two years.
And I said, now since I got to be chairing, and this going on for the summer year, and I said, you still ain't.
Oh, really? You're still active in the party?
I'm still not.
I'm asking you about that later.
I'm still the president of the Freedom Democratic Party.
Wow.
And after I elected President of the Freedom Democratic Party, then I was, they also elected me as being the co-author, and I had to go to all these, 17 and 18 different communities, you know, to set up a meeting.
And so I was the co-author, and they didn't have the chair for that day on up to the day.
Tell us a little bit more about the early days of getting ready and choosing the delegation that would go to Atlantic City, the precinct meetings that were held to elect this group.
Yeah, but I said, we were, at that time, we were all the commutes and most of meeting, you know, had different nights.
And we were always with me on Wednesday night, and I had a different night, all the pig and red and mys and all of them.
But we were all, and they were 30, and we would have our kind of wide meeting.
And that's where everybody in the kind of would come to this meeting.
And that's where we picked out the people, you know, to go to these different communities, not the kind of wide meeting they were 30, and so we see a meeting every 30, and that's wonderful.
Let's vote.
Yeah.
Okay, we're going.
Well, the Freedom Democrats lost their challenge in Atlantic City.
Right.
But then they decided to challenge the seating of the congressional delegation in that would be in January of 1965, saying that that delegation was illegal because blacks could not vote in the elections that are in the election.
Were you active in that movement to get Mrs. Hamer and Mrs. Devine and Mrs. Ray seated in Washington?
Yeah, we were involved in all of that.
And I said, we'd always, when something like that happened, we, you know, that there is something we would always meet, you know, because I said the kind of would be real together.
And in a way, you meet, you know, you have a crowd, but at that time, we didn't have a center like we had now, you know, so we just needed this church, maybe like this 30, 30, 30, 30, 30, another community might have to have.
But that's the way we, you know, and we'll pick out our delegates, you know, who are we going to send and be the delegates from the Freedom Democrats party like that?
In Holmes County, were the ministers active in the movement or just a couple of them?
We had just a couple of ministers and a couple, I'm going to say, moving the couple, it was maybe like five or six minutes, maybe five or six or seven teachers involved in, you know, when it was real active, but not.
Why, why was that early on that the professionals were not active in the movement? You were, you were an exception.
Well, at that time, the preacher was a free ed and the teacher was a free ed too. And so we just couldn't, we would talk to him all the time, but we just couldn't never give him to find out why they were, well we know why they weren't coming.
I said a whole lot of people back then, then we were just really free ed. And then after some of them, you know, find out what was going on in the two, you know, ease on him, but the teachers and the preacher were really scared on the street.
I can see the teachers were afraid of losing their job, right? Because they had white superintendents.
What were the preachers afraid of? That's what I was really asking them, because they were, they were passing the black congregation.
But I guess they might have been, you know, considering, you know, maybe buying money from the banks or something like that, but they were just, and then some of them, you know, they were telling, well you, you, you know, better than the poor, that mess and all that kind of, and some of them except like that.
I know in some counties there were some ministers who were really working with the white people, the white people were sort of giving small favors.
Yeah, we had a little bit of that going on too.
You had those that you were, you could say you couldn't trust them.
Yeah, right.
That they would, something would happen, somebody would be a conversation and all of a sudden it would get back to the white folks.
And I, you know, you don't know teaching, some of them stated that right now they didn't come to the meme because I just don't spend as 12 and rate, you know, and wasn't nothing I could tell them until, and then later on one of the teachers got fired.
And so that was not here. We, I'm selling high school and they sent for me to come down there.
I said, when were they sent for me to come down there? And they already said that I was not, and I could tell them.
And so when I went down there, it was nothing there but teachers.
And I told them I said, well, now, I said, I'm surprised y'all had me to come down here.
I said, y'all, I heard the y'all said that I just don't spend as 12, rain, when I could tear y'all.
I said, let me tell you one thing. I said, now you're right, I said, I can't teach school.
I said, you can't read a blueprint.
And I said, I said, what I got, they don't teach that in college.
I said, that had to come from the man above, the guy that could and not have been afraid to speak out.
And I said, but I tell you what I said before the sun goes around, I said, the teacher never fight.
I'm going to be back in his position.
And so they know on that end and they come back and told me he had a job back.
And then that's when I told him, I said, now let you know that when you together, you can get playing dumb, but when you divide.
And I said, that's what they was trying to do, keep the teachers and the preachers from the black wife, what we call them, men.
So the teachers were fired and they got their jobs back.
Yeah.
And you were helpful in that.
We went, we went, we went, how did you go about doing that?
We just called the superintendent and told me, you're going to put him back or you're going to put the boycott on.
And that's all it took.
Yeah, you must have had some power.
We had power.
Yeah.
In her wonderful new book on the Holmes County Movement, Thunder of Freedom, Susan Lorenzi Sojourner writes that you were, quote, unquestionably the Durant Movement leader.
And that you spent, quote, several dangerous years opening up the predominantly White Hill towns of Durant, West, and Goodman.
First of all, tell us something about Sue and Henley Lorenzi, the white volunteers who came to Homes County and the Fall of 64 and stayed for a while.
Well, they're, Sue and Henley were here in least five years.
And they were real active and anything that we were, you know, trying to do, they were writing that word.
Well, they were, they were, they worked the whole five years.
They were here, you know, if anybody, and everybody's seen the love of them.
And, and, and we just all worked in that a year.
A lot of this was Sue and Henley at first.
We were living in the, in the community center and a lot of activity after that around that.
This, the community center, well, tell us how it got built and, and what it's important.
It was for you and your, and the community in organizing.
Well, and the son, I mean, you know, he was kind of a community thing, you know, different wanted volunteers, you know, and then help get it built out in my eyes.
Yeah. And so that's, that's where it, it, it got built.
And then, what did I say when we first started, you know, we didn't, we didn't have that.
But about Sue and Henley, me and him kind of spearheaded everything.
And that's where that center got built, you know, just volunteer.
And one of the things that was coming out of that was a health clinic.
That was started in the fall of 1964.
A diversion here. Tell us a little bit about healthcare in the state.
When you, when you got sick, when you were growing up, what was available to you?
Do you go to doctors, the hospital, what, what kind of services were there in the county?
One of the, serving in the kind of, back in the name was real, pofor black folk.
I mean, cause, you know, someone didn't go to a hospital or doctor, his name was Dr. Brock and he used to go around, you know.
Two different people's home, you know, if they would get sick or something like that,
cause black didn't go to a hospital too much, cause they don't have no money or something like that.
And no clinic, but now, he, doctor, they were, you know, someone, you know, couldn't even get the people out.
But they don't have no cars and, they don't have no good roads and things.
And they had to walk there and they were, he was real bad back there in the day.
I believe there weren't any black doctors in the county.
No, no black doctors.
Are there now?
Yes, black doctors in the county.
So you were dependent on white doctors?
White doctors.
Did you go to their offices where they're segregated waiting rooms and things?
Do you remember?
Yeah, I remember all of that.
I never go, but I remember, you know, that they had, you know, rooms with a white room with a black.
Never, never, like, train station, you know,
bus and, you know, police.
And when somebody got sick later on while you had, first of all, the health clinic with the nurses who were there,
and then the doctor who came up from Jackson, but then you had the community health centers.
And you have them here and now, right?
Yeah, right.
Are they effective in helping people?
Yeah, they're really effective.
Now we've got my son.
I mean, a married clinic, you know, they got a clinic in Lexington.
And they don't be a one here in New Rent.
They got a big clinic up here on Toyota going to Lexington.
And it helps a whole lot of black and one in Lexington.
So they're real cool, I believe.
Yeah, they're just...
So we don't have no problem about it, you know, people getting sick of it here.
And all about there, that's part of the comprehensive community health center movement across the country.
And nearly 40 million needy people are getting help from these non-clinics centers.
And it all started here in my...
Yes, right.
That was started in my...
It's a health clinic.
It's quite an accomplishment for all of you.
Okay, we're going to talk about political organizing.
How did you go about the job of organizing, of getting people together and developing what became some power for you?
Well, as I say here, when I started in New Rent,
when the school of...
what is called the city school, New Rent High School.
Now, it was segregated, you know, when no blacks up there.
And Mayor Levin thought you might have heard of him.
He was still right, lawyer.
Yeah, I knew me, yeah.
Yeah, home was county.
And so he got involved with us up here at the school.
And so we had a meeting one night and we had, you know, been talking about the school.
And so he...
We pointed him.
He was a 24-year-old school up there.
And then he came back and told him, you know, that we need to point...
To let two blacks, you know, they...
They didn't want two blacks to be on the board up there.
Because he always wants you to be the odd number.
And so they...
They pointed me and Mr. D. F. One, so we just...
The school was a 42-black that served up there on that board.
And so then we got from there, but at that time,
it's both been...
When they had a Prumple Law,
Superintendent One, both been black and one, both been white.
So everyone owned that away for a while, but right now,
the Prumple and the Superintendent is right right now.
But that's where we're all going to have to...
And so we tried to get them to merge with the county.
But they figured if they...
Yeah, that they were going to control.
And so they fought that.
And so they wouldn't communicate...
Or couldn't connect with the county school.
They wanted to stay up back on their...
You know, they were going to be in power.
And they were...
They were...
They fought that.
And so then they were finally...
They made a separate school.
They were...
They were finally...
They figured they'd do that.
They wanted to lose control of it.
They didn't know they were...
They wanted to lose control of it anyway.
So after God liked that,
then a whole lot of white people moved out of...
Out of...
Out of Durant.
And so right now,
God how this would say on him,
but that was the first thing, you know.
And then after that,
then we...
We almost raised this risk cap.
I mean, couldn't go on ever white, you know.
And you...
You go in the back, you know,
and they were so afraid back then.
So...
When did you do that?
And how did you go about integrating the cafe?
Well, and...
And I said, we meet...
Meet everyone at the night.
And we decided that...
That certain win at night
that, you know, what day we were going up there.
And so now, Blackpool was kind of afraid too.
So, over there by the post,
all in front of that cafe,
the street would pull them right,
but it didn't go to few of us go up in there.
And so...
And then after we went up in there,
and then we didn't have no more problems, you know.
Out of...
Out of going in there.
So when you went in,
this was after the law had been passed.
So it was illegal.
Yeah, yeah.
And you went in and what did...
Did they serve you right away?
They serve.
They...
They had every night, like,
you know, threat.
They didn't turn you away or...
No, we weren't going to be turned away.
Yeah.
So people,
until you took that initiative,
why Blacks just assumed that
something bad would happen to them if they went in?
Oh, yeah, they were afraid.
That would have been something going to happen.
But...
We didn't win in there, you know.
We just went on in there.
And then later on,
the nation,
and then he had...
Well, the day the barbed,
they had...
You know, when you...
You could buy ice train there,
but they had two signs.
You know, they had the train station.
Black water fountain, white water fountain.
And so I knew everything,
so we had...
We said we're going to do that,
that's sad.
And so that we're in the night,
so that's what we're going to do.
And the first time we had a side,
he had a young and polished dog.
He had tied up everybody's...
And so we talked to the mayor,
and told him he better make him move that dog.
Or he...
We don't get rid of him.
And so he finally moved the dog,
so we went around there.
And I had him, he said,
before I settled in a niggin' ice train,
I let one of them worse say,
oh, why say, I'm going to some,
it down to the ground.
It didn't have a mag, right?
And the song was working at the working farm with bank.
That's where you retire from.
And so now I tell him,
I said, well, you know what?
I said, well, you're able to get you a mat
and set the song so up by.
I said, well, the next time we come right in the box of my ice
train, I said,
we...
And they don't be no side of it,
saying, oh, black,
all colored and white.
And so that's...
that was on the sear.
And so that's suddenly,
we are all we're part of on the square,
you know, when we get to go sing.
And that's what we meet at, you know,
at part of the street,
and then we get in the van,
or whatever it has, you know,
to go to...
And so now I know,
when I look part of it in the front of the day,
I've gone in there, no sign of the period of it.
And it wasn't going down.
And so...
From that day on, you know,
you go either one, you want it to.
And then the nation was a figure wicker at that time,
you know, it all had black...
Now, the Black...
The Black Lady was the grocery store, right?
Yeah, grocery store.
So that was the one, you know,
the black bag,
boy, the white, black,
boy, got in the fight.
I think the black boy won the fight,
but he fired him,
and he didn't and kept the white.
And so then we met that Wednesday night,
and I told him what we were going to do.
And so we called and told him
he had to get that black boy,
the job, the black guy,
he just fired both of them,
so he refused to do it.
And so then we boy-cut it.
And so we got down,
not too far from the store.
We don't park a lot,
but we, you know,
he had to be a certain dancer.
And so I never get it.
I think maybe that's not that money.
I had about three or four white families
came to go to the store.
And they said,
what you know,
we said,
we boy-cutting the store.
They called he fired black boy
and kept the white boy.
And they said,
what I don't blame,
you all said,
we can go to another store,
we can't keep on around the thing
and went on all.
Was that unusual that whites
would cooperate with you?
Yeah, sure.
But they chose
supposedly because they said,
we can go somewhere else.
And then the white brother
that brought the chickens and things.
They had, you know,
18 wheels of trucks loaded with chickens and things.
And he went there.
He didn't unload.
He didn't come out by.
He stopped.
He said, I don't know what you all don't.
They said, whatever you don't,
he said, you keep doing.
He said, you're going to give what you want
because this is the first time I ever
come here with a load of chickens
and had to kill all of them back.
And so then the next day,
he called me
and said, well,
we don't got rid of them.
The white boy said.
And I said, well,
I said, we'll be meeting this Wednesday night.
I said, I can't make that to see your knives.
I can go back to them,
to the meeting.
So that Wednesday night,
we met and I told them what it happened.
And they said,
and some of them were,
they're really with me and some said, well,
he's going to take son of the leg.
And I said, I don't care who he sent it.
I said, we said,
we're going to do it.
I said, if you want to can,
then that's good.
I said, we don't got what we asked for.
And so I said, we're going to lift the back.
And then after that,
he went out of radio spots
and he's positive until he went out of bed.
Oh, really?
You see,
interesting story.
You're talking about schools
and desegregation first
was came in 1965,
with just a handful of bucks
attending all white schools.
What happened after that?
Well, the first incident I had,
real bad,
and school,
it was in a talent count.
And never that,
the school was in,
going in,
even in a talent count.
And so,
this young man,
I think he's run a brand
by the one called me,
called,
is in my kind of school,
that's what it was.
And asked me,
would I go there and see
what it had to have to have a brand song?
And so, at that time,
as I said, I was building houses,
even if I was putting top on house,
somebody called me,
that was in trouble,
I'd, you know,
I don't know how to go see by.
And so, that,
I'm on and I went over there,
and so,
I never taken a gun with me,
and I'm not sick of,
I knew if I had a gun,
you know, they're going,
and they stopped you,
they're going to put you in jail,
something like that,
so I didn't get no gun,
but,
and when I got over there,
before I got over,
I couldn't see nothing but blue lights.
And so, I said,
well, what happened?
Oh, and so,
when I said,
go back in the middle of the mountain,
I said, no, go on,
and I got this one,
go here.
And so, when I got on there,
you can,
you know, the shed,
all his people there,
the consoles,
and, you know,
just white people,
you know, were gone.
And so,
I just got out and went on in there,
and so, when I walked in the room,
the shed was in there.
And he said,
can I help you?
I said,
I'm looking for the principal.
He said,
use on the cover, man.
I said,
I'm looking for the principal.
Are you FBI?
I said,
I'm looking for the principal.
Oh, you're the take.
And I,
every time you have me,
or when I tell you,
I'm looking for the principal,
so I guess you find out
that I was going to ask his question.
And he said,
the principal is not here.
He said,
he's,
not here to sit,
and so,
and I came home out,
and I,
the school just had,
the lives he said,
have for you,
in the immigration.
And so,
when I got come out to school,
I,
the black would,
Fred,
to talk to me.
I guess they were never,
and so, when I got,
I took it back to the hallway,
one of the young man,
I guess because he,
He had a group, you know, he was saying different programs together.
And he said, well, that boy and mother worked on that car, that time I was at the chicken
plate.
And I drove all the way from there to Carson, and I got to Carson.
They told me she had come back to Car Disco, and I had to drive back from Carson back
to Car Disco.
And then I found a founder and she said, well, he's up there.
And I said, hey, I know the carer, it didn't work.
And I said, yeah, I know him.
And so she said, that's what he did.
So I went up there.
And he finally come to the door.
I said, I know you come to dove with nobody else.
I said, and he said, well, I didn't rate that girl.
They called the kid.
They wouldn't go to crack or they thought they had killed it.
And he said, no, sir.
We mean, I mean, co-net girl, I have such a school with Ellen Ray.
And he said, what happened?
He went at this house and knocked on the woman.
The girl came out and they went on, you know, they were going to do.
And when they finished, I guess she got ready to go back to the house.
I guess a mum and dad found out that she went out to the house.
And so when she seen all of them life on the back in her house, she wouldn't go back there.
She went home with him.
And he slept on.
And his dad, as I go with dad, didn't he?
And I noticed the girls in his house.
And they found out that he had let them come in his house.
And he's in the vehicle in New Moan and the flute.
Well, they got him out and knocked him up.
What happened eventually?
Did he, was he brought to trial or anything?
Well, after they found out that I was in it.
And they had set up a cold date.
But that cold day nearly come for her.
And he ain't missing, because there's no cry out.
From that day to this day.
And they just dropped their lights out.
And they found out that he had some support.
But I'm saying, you know, and he wouldn't kill them, nothing like that.
And he didn't rape because they were going together.
Yeah.
The operation.
And once the Supreme Court decided in the Holmes County decision in 1969, the US Supreme
Court, that the time for all the liberate speed was passed.
And it was schools were going to have to be integrated immediately.
What happened here?
When whites were faced with having lots of black kids going to their schools?
But it was kind of tough of him.
But we went to do that, how we had some pounds that put their kids up there.
And a whole lot of them did not put them up there.
Because I guess they'd press something going on to them.
But I believe the boys won.
They'd actually remember to put their kids up.
And it was had to be a cell phone and knew these ones.
And so they put their kids up there.
And so none of the people who found out that there's nothing to have them.
And then the other people went.
And so now it just about told them, black, it might be a few white up there.
Where did the white school?
West to the private school in the last month.
These were citizens' counsel schools at first.
Yeah, they come private.
You come private school in, but they come and they don't name them Christian schools and
all that kind of stuff.
But it's here about the white school that's schooled up in West.
So schools are pretty much segregated today too.
Only blacks are in the public schools.
They have black teachers and superintendent.
Back to your organizing.
Sue writes that quote, you ran strict meetings, find people for not showing up, and raking offenders
over the coals for their fears, false excuses, and inactivity.
And despite this, or maybe because of it, derand meetings had more people attending, more
money raised, and more project involving more folks than anywhere else in Olm's County.
That's a lot to deal with.
Let's start by talking, and you mentioned this several times, the real fears that people
had about getting involved.
How did you deal with that?
How did you get them to overcome their fears and take chances?
Well, as I said, I had been wagon with black people, and young people all moved all my
lives, and they had quite a bit of confidence.
Whatever I said, someone would try it.
But now it was kind of hard for a while.
But they finally come on in there, and then someone was thinking that they're going to
lose their job if they got involved in this or that.
And so we just know that if you got a job and then you got your freedom, you don't
have too much.
And so that way I always, and I always just had a whole lot of patience.
And so I just was wagon along with them and encouraged them.
But as I said, we'd be a death for a long time.
And then we didn't have no son of a hand to that, but we had a little shotgun out in
the country that we were using, you know, for an hour meeting play.
And we would meet out there every Wednesday night.
And every Wednesday night, after we get opened up by them, they would be a carload of white
people would come through and shoot all the top of that bed.
And then shoot in the bed, but they would shoot all the top of it.
And after they shoot all the top of it, you'd come this way and then go around that way
and hit another one, come back to do rent.
And so that next Wednesday night I had organized a group and I told them, I said, we're going
to bring some guns out here.
This Wednesday night, you know, don't shoot in the car.
Just shoot all the car like they did and shoot all the building.
And so I had about three or four on this side of the sun and three or four on this side
of the sun.
And so when they came through that nation Wednesday night and just that's we opened up,
they put in their own time, they come out, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop and go on around.
So this time when they come on, they shoot all the building.
And when they pass the building and they went down that way, then my group over five
over there here and they turn around and come back.
They didn't go all the way around that time.
They turn around and come back on this side when they got back on this side.
Then the group up there over five over there here.
And so then I heard it, they don't.
They got back and doing that.
But not go out there and say, they got all kind of machine going.
Like they were no machine going.
They did different, you know, fine.
And so fine as they lay down and then we meet at this place and we met up at the church
over there called Saigon Pagoda at church.
But then some of the snakes people, you know, were here too.
And so they was coming on up that road and going, come on to the meeting.
And when they came by this church, they seen this rope.
They had a red rope.
They had soaked them some gas and they kept that rope and the church and tied around
the pool up here and brought it back out low, you know, and sit in the fire.
But just so having the law, they sent them by there and they seen that rope.
So they pulled it out to church.
And that's the only thing that's written that church is still sending them.
So then I called the sheriff.
I'm a smith, he was a sheriff, and he's, he's a red neck, I call him.
He was saying, he didn't care what happened all that kind of stuff.
He wasn't going to do this and he wasn't going to do that.
And so little bit of an old eye calling him back.
I said, but I tell you what, I said, you don't have to send nobody out here.
I said, but if I call you back, I said,
we're going to be calling you for you to send the ambulance out here.
I said, anybody, we can't find a morning straight now.
We're going to kill him.
And then he sent a devil to that.
Yeah.
So what ever happened to the nonviolent movement?
Were you always armed when you went out, when you went to meetings, when you, did you
carry a gun in your car when you went out?
Did you?
Well, that's some of my hard-earned care to go on.
And I said, now when I went to my house, I didn't know all that was going on.
And I thought, I just wanted to call the ambulance.
I said, man, you see, you thought that they had killed the boy.
But the reason I didn't come up, I know that if they catch you with a gun, they're going
to have something that they're going to frame.
So if they would stop me, they never would have found a gun on me.
I didn't really care no gun.
We don't know when that before I started to get a gun in it, right?
But when they would come into your community and attack you, your own property while you
would fire back like that?
Yeah, I had some people, you know, that I know about us.
But that's no time that I asked them to know the brain, some weapons out there when we
died in the country.
But when we meet here and do random stuff, we'd have them.
And some of them was trick or having to be great.
But that time I did ask them, right in my death, you know.
But you know, I started here, I know about it.
But they let them know, you know, they'll buy them, you know, the building one was going
to stop us from meeting.
The Boatting Rights Movement in Holmes County and in the rest of the South really got
a boost by the passing of the Boatting Rights Act in 1965, which made it much easier to register
and vote, particularly with the federal registrars coming in as they did.
And the movement changed during that time.
You were talking about the professionals and how before in the early days they were either
afraid or did not participate.
But that sort of changed once the Boatting Rights Act came to an end.
And Sue says that you, despite the fact that they were not active before, that you really
wanted them in the movement, is that right?
No, they weren't active.
I say, you know, me every time I would meet, that was two of the things that I would bring
up with the teachers and the preachers.
Because I figured that the preachers didn't have nothing, they should have been afraid,
you know, or they wouldn't work.
Some of them out of the barn, money, you know, from banks or something like that.
But then as I said, when the teachers, they were, you know, we didn't have white students
telling them about that.
When they got back, we had a black student attending at that time.
But the white, oh, you know, that's what it was.
And so.
But let's move then.
And I'll be finished shortly.
But this is just fascinating to the election campaigns.
And that you were so important there in organizing these communities and getting the boat out
and selecting candidates.
The first was in the general election of 1966.
I believe Ralph Hays ran for Congress in that district.
But there was just really a preview of 1967 when you decided to run a slate of candidates
in Holmes County.
And that became one of the most famous elections in Mississippi history for the result.
Talk a little bit about how you, how did you go about selecting?
If you were going to run through all the county offices or state representative, did
you have lots of people volunteering to want to do it?
Yeah, but at that time, and I said, whenever we would select candidates or something like
that, we would always, not in the commute to mean, we would always do it at the county
wide, which would own a three-cent.
And that's when we would choose out of candidates.
Sometimes we would point our ass and then some of them would volunteer because, you know,
Reverend Eddie Clark, he was the first black that was, that became a candidate for US
conference.
He was in jail.
Yeah, well, so that election you had represented Clark.
Now, had he been active in the Freedom Democratic Party for a while?
And you had other teachers and, and were the ministers getting involved now in the late
60s or were they still on the outside?
Some of them came in.
So you had a larger movement, a larger party.
And represent, Robert Clark became the first African American to sit in the Mississippi
State Legislature in the 20th century.
And tell us how you got him elected.
But I said we came and, you know, all that, as I said, more will take place on the third
Sunday because the community, you know, it just being made just as a community.
But that third Sunday, everybody from the different age of other county would be there.
And that's when we would choose out of candidates.
And we'd also, you know, by, you know, how, how they would support now, community, you
know, if they weren't supporting their community, meeting, you know, on Wednesday night or whatever
night they had, we would be kind of skeptical of them.
But they, they had to be sure they faced for us.
They're not aside that we're going to support them at the county.
And so then at that time, as I said, we were, we were ready to gather.
And if we, to you, that we were going to support you at the county day, and then if somebody
else side would come out against you, well, we were strong enough at that time to let them
know that we were going to support you.
And if you want to run against him, then you're going to be out there on your own.
And so we would pick out a county day like that on Wednesday.
And that's when we came with Mr. Hayden, Robert Clark, and Dr. McLean, and everybody
side the wrong would always mean to let him on that Thursday, not in the community meeting.
In other words, you were very careful with these first races that you got the best people
to run.
Yeah, that's right.
And, and you had a decision to make in 1967 that either you could have, uh, representative
Clark, for example, could have run in the Democratic primary against a white candidate,
or you could have run an independent slate and waited until the November election.
Why did you decide to wait till November instead of running in the primary election?
Well, we think kind of know that there might be our best change at that time.
Why would that be?
Better to just run in one election than to do it in two.
Well, as I said, Reverend Nick Craw, he put it where I'm known and, and, and he, he was
communicated with some of the white, you know, was put in, in, in this corner and most,
all, all of the black and so we're not a putting that he defeated.
But he was kind of, he ain't been in that long time.
But, but we all got behind and all of them said they were going to support him and, and
that's where it needed them.
I don't know why, just why we picked him up with, to having two changes with the award.
Yeah, the, and if the, the chances were a lot better running in the general election,
the, asking people who hadn't voted before you, you're only asking to vote once.
Yeah, right.
Um, how did you get the vote out?
What, tell me, we're, we call about election day.
What, take me through election day, what you were doing.
Well, on, on any election day, I said I would just call out on day and every, community
that had a meeting, I would go around and that's what we were, you know, being strong
about it called, is I said I was a co-ordinate and, and I would go to, at that time of doing
that, guppman picking, my, to recruit, old pegging rest, election, and Howard, and old pegging
rest, every community had, had a meeting place.
I said I was 17, 18, and we would go there and, and, and be pushing out of accountability,
and then sometime in the accountability would go out with us too.
And that's the way we, we were, we were strong back in that then.
We, we supported them, you know, just back on get it back.
And you did you have, uh, carpooling on election day, or, you made sure you had, you know,
the, the, they, they, they had, uh, we're whites, we're able to vote pretty freely, or was
their intimidation.
Now I'm a, I was a intimidation, I'm a poll, some, some, some, some poll, pray, you know,
we have a problem, not too often called day.
Cause they, they, they knew we were mean, you know, and they know that we, we was together.
And they know that this thing, it was so long.
And I, I, I, I'm, I'm crazy not to call someone the white, you know, they might not have
come in there, you know, cause they didn't know what they'd raise, we're going to do that,
like we didn't know, maybe what I raised going to do.
But some of them didn't know it had been so long, and, and some of them, you know, very
cooperative.
Well, that again speaks to the, you're just south of here in Madison County, you had
intimidation at the polls going on well into the 1970s.
Oh, yeah.
Home's kind of was the strongest kind of, the freedom of them got bothered in.
I, within other kind of, but home's kind of was, son of strong, and it's, and it's,
dear, put it strong today.
And the freedom democratic party is alive and well in home's County.
And home's kind.
Well, we see a meat the same son in the same time.
Well, I want to thank you very much for, for talking with us, but I'd like before we
close for you to talk a little bit about what you've been doing lately, about your own
family, about conditions today.
Well, I told my, I mean, my wife, she paid $9.1, and we got a dollar, but they don't
say anything.
And they never did all.
This really made up because I was going all the time, as I said, it wasn't a night
pay, as I was going, as I said, I had them 17, 18, kind of like the meat.
And so, she nailed it all.
Say anything about, you know, you stand in the road too much, I think she appreciate
what I was trying to do.
And so, now I just...
It's important to have that support, wasn't it?
Yeah, that's right.
And so, and then I had other people, you know, they would tell me and I told them, and then
they'd ask me, I don't say, you put up food on them different folk.
I said, well, they don't worry about me.
That's all I did all my life.
I said, what's concerned about?
And I said, and the main thing I said, and I still said that I nailed it.
Hate white folk.
But I said, I only think that I didn't like, you know, where they were, was treating
the black folk.
And I said, and that way you can get along and you can mix up with anybody.
And the main thing, I always have been outspoken, whatever I have to say, I don't care who I'm
at or who it is, I'm gonna say it.
And that goes a long ways too, and I said, I want all of the white, up black, no, I
wouldn't forsake.
I said, I wasn't out here trying to accept no money, I put no money in my park.
I said, come out, they weren't without that.
I said, I don't think I want this free.
And I said the same thing, I said the day I said in the 60s and early 60s, that you don't
need an un-no black, you don't need an un-no white.
And I said that and then it'll be not going to red, now we don't need all black kind of
date, and we don't need all white kind of date.
I always think it should be mixed, and I feel that way today.
One question, what do you think have been the most positive changes that have taken place
since the 1950s and 60s, and what remains to be done?
What are the major problems facing the black community and Mississippi?
Well, as I said, you had to keep letting them know, just because you might be the majority,
that no mean that the majority will always be the best thing.
And so I said, a whole lot of people, they're going to support you because you're black.
And this is that, I said, well that's not the name of the game.
I said, God didn't intend for it to be like that.
I said, God had it been pretending to be that he was for all black, all white.
And like I said, the president, we got none there, we got a leg.
We were going to have to let him be white, but we didn't have to give him any.
And I said, he wouldn't have been the second time that he was for the white book.
And I said, that's just so you're right there that God noted that thing need to be mixed.
And from the long that I live, I will always stand by it.
I don't need none all black, all white.
Is there anything else you'd like to add to our discussion?
Well, I appreciate you all coming.
And I hope I didn't get to read about it.
Well, I mean you have made such an impact on this community, on the state.
And we are just delighted that you were willing to tell your story for us
and for all the many people who will be listening and watching to you when the museum opens in Washington.
Thank you again, Mr. Bruegel very much.
Thank you. I got a picture.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.